[Music]
Sarah welcome back to the GSB it's
always so fun to be at the GSB although
this is a much fancier GSB than the one
I went to I almost went down the down
the street but you moved the birds so
now I'm totally confused we are so
excited to have you as our first speaker
not only as a GSB Alum but you have
literally done it all I think you have a
story that can speak to each and every
single person in this audience and just
to paint a very small picture of what
that looks like we have a short
graphic oh my God so you can see so I'm
born and raised in Northern Ireland
you've rode crew at Oxford you took on
Wall Street as the girl facing the bull
you've worked alongside Jack dorsy
you've launched two IPOs you've met the
[Music]
[Laughter]
queen I did and now you're here with
me it's just being a constant
[Applause]
rise and so I'm hoping the luck of the
Your Luck of the Irish rubs off on me in
this brief time that I have with you on
stage but if we take a look back at
where it all started it seems like luck
really had nothing to do with it and so
can you tell us what it was like growing
up in Northern Ireland and how that
shaped your perspective in life
trajectory sure I I would never say luck
doesn't have a play in it it absolutely
does but it's definitely luck is
whatever the the preparation meets
opportunity but you got to grab it um I
grew up in Northern Ireland I realized
today I have a very bad American accent
but if we were to go and have probably
an LPF or something you'd start to hear
the northern Irish accent coming out um
but yeah I grew up during the troubles
and it was not a pretty time I grew up
on the border just outside dairy um my
local times col stban had the absolute
it still is if you go look it up in in
Wikipedia or whatever had had the the
jubia honor of being the most bombed ton
of its size for I think three decades
and that includes during the Bosnian
Serbian crisis and so on so we still won
on that front um but on the other side
it was an amazing place for community
and we'll Arc back to it I'm sure when
we come to next door but I feel like I
got to see Next Door in real life before
there was a thing of virtual next door
because my mom was the local nurse my
dad was the local Personnel manager of
the local Mill the whole village existed
because of this Mill was founded by the
Quakers and there was rarely a night
where someone didn't knock on our door
for some reason um whether they had a
medical problem my mom was actually the
Midwife so if you were giving birth and
most births happened at home even at
that stage my mom would be there to
catch the baby um usually pushing the
doctor out of the way she thought they
were useless which always makes me laugh
because my brother's not a doctor so she
likes to remind him it's not that useful
um my dad dad would be there if you
needed a job if you needed help with
money um and there could be all sorts of
societal things social things going on
um and they were always there and I
think that was just a great grounding
for me on what it was what it meant to
invest back in your community and in
doing that what that does for you U my
parents are now in their 80s they still
live in that same house and they're
still a formidable part of their
Community now all those experiences
growing up and finding strength in
community LED you to the GSB where
there's an equally strong
Community what were some of the key
opportunities that you took advantage of
during your time here and lessons that
you took away that you continue to apply
today yeah so so probably the the
biggest reason I ended up here was a
willingness to take a lot of risk for
better or worse um even as a kid growing
I was funny I had a doctor's appointment
this week and the doctors was asking me
you know issues and I was like not a lot
he's like you ever broken anything I was
like oh broken things let's talk about
that and when I started kind of spewing
them all off he's like what did you do
and I was like I don't know I just I was
a risk taker as was a tomboy growing up
and that kind of kept going through
career um I when I was at Oxford in my
undergrad I someone offered me the
opportunity to go off to Ghana I was
well I was um actually my degree is
called metalogy economics management but
Material Science and my tutor at Oxford
was figuring out how to release gold out
of sulfide ORS and it was moving from a
lab process to an industrial process
called bio and he said would you like to
go over there and actually see it in
action and I I was like Count Me In I
had no idea what I was signing up for
like getting to like no idea what a mine
is like in a place like Ghana at that
time um and really kind of showing up
and finding both some amazing things
that happened but also really
recognizing a place I didn't feel
particularly welcome um there were
almost no women on that mine at all uh
so that was a really good moment of like
I took a risk
part of it played up but not all of it
so I kind of came home a little bit tail
between my legs actually Frank Frankly
from that experience I I zagged the
other way Joy McKenzie very different
but because I'd been on that mine they
sent me to South Africa and that was
another moment of like taking a risk so
I went to South Africa in 1996 right
after AP paride had ended um it wasn't
particularly safe so another kind of a
little bit taking life risks as well as
career risks um but it was such an
amazing time to go see a country being
born the rainbow Nation Mandela had
risen um and the country that at the
time it makes me sad a little to see
South Africa of today but that really
wanted to kind of bring about this whole
new world where the rainbow nation
everyone kind of joined hands um because
I went to McKenzie this is the moment
where I get to the GSB I'd never heard
of an MBA Frankl I had no idea what this
thing was but I was like to 2 years you
can pay for me to go somewhere for two
years and I can pick where and and in my
complete naivity and it could have been
seemed by cuis I really only applied to
two schools um and I was so incredibly
blessed that I picked to come to this
one um and frankly again it was a little
bit of a risk like I didn't really know
anything about California I'd never seen
the school till the day I showed up to
move in and drove down Palm Drive Right
how many people have done that for the
first time and you're literally like I'm
in a dream this can't be real in fact
when I lived in Schwab and I'd open up
my blinds every morning and the sky was
always blue remember I grew up in
Northern Ireland this is a big
difference I literally called it The
Truman Show if you've ever seen that
movie I'm like I feel like I'm inside
the bubble and you know everyone's chipp
good morning Sarah good
morning Professor saloner I'd love to
talk about strategy
today but uh yeah it was an amazing
outcome so I guess like the Arc is take
risks you think that you you know you
have to keep doing these things to build
expertise and that you know somehow if
you zag it's going to be all these risks
you're going to take it's so it's all in
your head like absolutely all in your
head and I think my big learning in
getting to Stamford and even subsequent
is it is really good to take zigzag
risks and to lean in to just these
moments like it was a cocktail party
that took me to South Africa it was a
conversation with a partner at McKenzie
he was like you worked on a mine and you
know again it was very much community
and social interactions that layered on
top of a career path so not only have
you talked the talk but you have walked
the walk with taking a phenomenal risks
particular around your career at Square
so prior to square you were working at
Goldman you'd been there for over 10
years you would reach the level of
managing director had a very successful
tenure and then decided to take the the
huge risk to join this small relative ly
uncertain company called Square can you
tell us what motivated that decision and
what was going through your head at the
time yeah so I definitely hit a moment
actually at Goldman during the the great
financial crisis so
0809 where I really felt I lost that
moment of like purpose and my parents as
you can hear kind of are very big on a
reason to be in the world um today I
think a lot about this iy guy framework
if you know it Japanese framework so
it's you know what the world needs what
you're good at what you're passionate
about and then importantly what you can
get paid for right with the bottom it's
a hobby and this makes it a job um I
when I looked at that the great fin that
moment when you know Goldman was on the
front page of the uh of Vanity Fair I
think it was as the vampire Rolling
Stone magazine as the vampire squid or
the vampire yeah vampire squid it was a
hard moment my parents were calling me
and kind of checking in like is
everything okay and uh you know who do
you work for and like there's a lot of
fear and I'm I'm very proud of of my
work at Goldman I'm proud of the firm
and what we did but it it made me
realize that for me personally purpose
was in some ways everything now it still
took me three years to EXT extract
myself because I had a lot of fear at
the time you know first of all the world
had almost ended from an economic
standpoint so you did not take having a
job lightly at all number two I had two
very young kids at the time and you know
my job kind of worked for me so it was
hard as a working mom to say I'm going
to throw all those balls up in the air
and we'll just see how they land on the
other side and I'm going to go into
corporate is kind of how people talk
about it but in the end it was a push
from a couple of mentors I actually did
a small hop to Salesforce so I give Mark
Ben off a lot of credit for kind of
pulling me out of Goldman and saying you
really would be a better operator it was
also moments of learning about myself
like these talks i' I've been to many of
them where I've listened to just
incredible people so I'm going to start
you low and you're you're you're free
from the top is going to Crescendo from
here but I think of them as um it's
almost like you're creating your own uh
Patchwork quilt you're going to get
pieces of advice and information
something that might inspire you
something that feels really apropo but
then you are going to create the the
quilt that works for you you and so in a
moment of being at Goldman coming home
one night and my uh at the time my
sociate had gotten promoted to VP and it
had taken us a couple years to get her
there it was a lot of fighting for her
it was a lot of learning about me
personally about what it means to be an
advocate for someone not just a mentor
so you're really standing up for them in
that meeting but she made it over that
finish line and I came home and I I'm I
keep pointing down here because my
husband's just sitting here but my my
was like crack open a bottle of wine a
bottle of champagne tonight and uh David
said something along the lines of I've
just never seen you this excited about a
stock pick and it kind of just like
annoyed like sitting on a bird annoyed
me for a long time I was like maybe I'm
actually doing the wrong thing and then
it was a moment of failure frankly that
made me finally make the decision so I
was in the the run to partner I really
thought it was my year I was super
excited I felt like I had checked all
the boxes um I know most of you in this
audience are complete overachievers
right so we all have boxes we're like I
got an A got an A+ I got an A always
done the right thing and in that moment
when I got the call it was an early
morning call that said this is not your
year and in fact partner years are every
two years so this is not your two years
um I went through the full ranges of
grief just in that morning I called my
husband he said I'll walk over um he
said don't cry don't cry in the office
I'm like okay it's okay to cry in the
office these days it was not okay at
that point um I walked on stairs I'm
Irish so I swore like the whole way
around the building we have a very big
lexicon of swear words when you're
Northern Irish um and once I'd walked
the building a few times and kind of
recomposed myself he said my husband's
sounding like such he should be up here
because I'm about to give him credit for
a second moment of like insight and I'll
pull it to something that's important
for all of you he said they've kind of
set you free and I was likewhat are you
talking about they have devastated me
and I he's like they've set you free
like if you want to stay and push to be
a partner full support but they've also
allowed you in this moment to really
look around and that's where that moment
of recognizing some of the things I was
way more passionate about I had kind of
lost my sense of purpose I knew I loved
developing and working with people which
being a research analyst wasn't perfect
for that because you are inherently
working in a small team you don't have a
lot of force multiplication out to other
people and then the third piece of
suddenly being somewhat free it all
worked in that moment um and so as you
think you're going to move through your
career you're going to end up in places
you're going to have kind of built to a
a local Maxima but I would kind of push
all of you to say when you want to go to
the next place sometimes you have to
tick down to go to the next because in
the end you want to build to a global
Maxima where you can have Maximum Impact
based on what you're passionate about
what you're good at what you're um uh
what you can get paid for like when all
of those circles align then you hit flow
it's an amazing moment and also having a
great mentor someone who will just
really truth talk to you is an
incredibly important piece of the puzzle
as well that's amazing and I really love
the metaphor that you use about patching
together that quilt and I'm sure that
must have guided you also on your
decision to ultimately leave Square
after again seeing it through its IPO
reaching a$ 30 billion market cap it's
very obvious in your story that this
idea of connection is hugely important
to you and in speaking with people that
have worked directly for you the
overwhelming feedback that I've heard is
that you touch every person's life that
you meet and make them feel like they're
the most important person in the room W
that's a direct quote um in terms of
your ability to be such a high achiever
and high performer
what's your secret to balancing that
with creating positive work cultures
that make people excited and passionate
to show up every day yeah so it it does
have to start with what is important to
you so if you ask me what is my
leadership like Mantra it is people
first because I fundamentally believe
that if you get the right people um and
you really let them fly that involves a
lot of giving them a lot of Aon autonomy
encouragement tough love but if you do
that then the a team with the B idea
will always beat the B team with the a
idea in my humble opinion like we could
probably debate that I'm sure there's
lots of case studies well you prove me
wrong sorry um but uh that's what I've
seen over the course of my career um
because in those tough times when you
have done that investment in people they
will run through walls for you and you
know if I go back to square for a moment
so Square was kind of a it was such a
shock to the system when I went there so
I went you know from can't remember how
big gold was at the time 35,000 40,000
people I went to Salesforce which was a
5,000 person company at the time which
also felt like so small and then I went
to square and it was 200 people it was
so strange to like be in a company where
you actually could see everyone every
single day not just like get to know
them but like literally every day you
were in their space um and if you look
at kind of the Arc of square at the time
it may probably have looked kind of very
straight up and to the right it's never
like that in said companies it is
absolutely you are paid to work on the
things that aren't working so you have a
tendency to always think nothing is
working when you're inside a company um
and that's also a good learning about
your own personal resilience and
remembering to actually celebrate but
when Square went public it was
awful we went we went public at a time
when the market had been closed for
pretty kind of like right now a very
elongated moment in time we had done our
last funding round at about a
3ish billion dollar valuation to make it
easier it's about $18 a share because
this is going to make it easy when I go
to the next point we hit the road the
the market is absolutely shitty um our
road show is not going that great I know
it's not going that great the bankers
are doing the best they can to be like
your book is almost covered and I'm like
that's not good IPO you need to be 20
times covered um and I had a team with
me that had never been kind of in the
market so they were like lapping in that
this is great the book is getting
covered and like and my stomach is just
going this is terrible but like you
can't stop you're on it and then we get
to that night of pricing which is
actually the final moment where you you
could actually say at that moment we're
pulling our offering you could say that
but like there's so much it's like
tsunami that's coming behind you
everyone's excited people have flown
into New York to ring the bell and so on
and so when the bankers priced the deal
at eight bucks a share so so I said 18
eight bucks a share like oh I just
remember that night it's like I
literally get goosebumps right now but
on the people front I really felt like I
was like no we can do this because you
know what it doesn't matter we sold we
actually what we did to kind of get to
the other side is we really shrank the
deal overall we sold 7% of our um of our
company most IPOs sell about 14% so we
said we hate this price but we're gonna
still push to the other side raise money
when you can I think we raised 280
million it's like such a small amount
actually in hindsight um but we're going
to push to the other side and then for
the next year our stock pretty much it
it broke offering I think it got as low
as six it was brutal and then so your
question about people is so important
because if you have the right team who's
Mission driven who's there for the right
reason and you have created um a
personal relationship almost with them
and they trust you they will run through
walls behind you um and that was that
moment when I saw that happen from a
square perspective and it's crazy right
we raised 280 million in that IPO I
think a year later we did a billion
dollar debt offering I think two years
later we did a three and a half billion
dollar debt offering at almost like 0%
it was crazy how the market then flipped
um and the stock really took off like
what I think the market cap um when I
left the the right before I announced I
was leaving we had a hundred billion
doll market cap because we were on the
road Marketing in Chicago and I remember
that day because it was a really big
deal to hit that market cap so you know
it but it really came down to the people
and having spent the time invested in
the people now your question was how do
you do that it's hard like you have to
take the time because people are
literally one person at a time you can
try to do more scaled up things so for
example I always since I started working
in corporate um I've always done a
Welcome Wagon so I kind of try to group
people up but whether it's once a month
or whatever anyone new joining Square
anyone new joining next door I meet with
them for an hour and it's my way of kind
of going around the room There's No
Agenda um but it's kind of a touchable
moment and I always tell them I want you
to leave this room there's only one
thing I want to leave this room I want
you to feel like I am super approachable
um I want you to see me as a human I
introduce myself as like a human being
not as a CEO or a CFO or a strategist or
whatever but I'm like I'm Sarah I have
two kids I have a great husband I grew
up here I want them to see me as a human
for two reasons number one when people
see you as very accessible they will
come and tell you their best ideas and I
totally believe that great ideas come
from everywhere in companies you don't
want just the product team thinking
about the product the finance team
thinks about Finance the marketing team
thinks about marketing you want everyone
all the time feeling like they're an
owner and they can have a point of view
on any part of the
company but the other thing that's
really important and it probably felt it
more keenly even as a CFO is risk you
also want people to feel that they can
speak up no matter what there's going to
be no cons quence I always tell them
come tell me what I hope is I'm going to
say we know about that here's the
mitigation we're in good shape but every
once in a while people bring you a risk
and you're like huh I hadn't thought of
that that let me go sweat a little and
then we're going to figure out how to go
mitigate it but to me that's like part
of the why is that you want to keep
those doors very open as a leader so
people will come talk to you tell you
it's how you'll build a great
company in terms of opening doors let's
turn to next door oh good segue well
played those Irish jeans
yeah so it's very clear how Mission
driven and value oriented you are and
again the focus of bringing people
together can you tell us a little bit
about what it's like to be at the helm
of a company whose sole purpose is to
build and strengthen communities and
human connectedness yeah so you all can
kind of see the arc for me why on the
one hand it was very hard to leave
Square um absolutely loved what we had
built was family almost but getting to
next door the purpose just made it all
seem like karmic almost um today next
door if you don't hopefully you knows if
you don't know next door I will be okay
if you leave right now and go sign up no
problem um but we serve about 85 million
neighbors verified Neighbors on the
platform 310,000 different communities
across 11 countries and we fundamentally
believe everyone's a neighbor so this is
a platform for anyone um you know we
can't let you on until you're 13 and up
but pretty much everyone is part of a
community um and the decision to go
there was number one that purpose just
really sang to me I'm sure we'll talk
about some of the themes whether it's
addressing themes of loneliness whether
it's addressing themes of things like
cost of living how do you help people
make money in their Community things
like crisis response in a moment of a
true big crisis when we all lived it
with Co but if you think about a
hurricane um hurricane Harvey blowing
into Houston was actually a seminal
moment in nextdoor's history as a
company because it was a moment when 911
went down it got overloaded and so the
mayor of Houston actually got on TV and
said hey if you know that nextd door app
download it and please start helping
your fellow neighbors because those were
the people that showed up in a boat to
take you off the roof of your house
whenever everything was flooded that's
who sticks out the hand and pulls you
out of the waters and they don't ask by
the way in that moment like how do you
vote do you believe in gun control like
humans will help humans in times of need
which is something I love about the
platform um so the purpose was big but
there was also an extra element of
feeling like I had to step up in the
world and and lean into that you can't
be what you can't see I felt like I had
spent a lot of my life on a stage often
talking to rooms of of women non binary
individuals and saying you know just do
it grab that leadership moment like we
have to show up for each other and so
there was definitely a moment of saying
oh I need to do that too um a little
terrifying at times but I wanted to say
hey women can be CEOs like I never want
my kids to grow up and not just see that
as a normal part of life um and women
can run public companies and it's tough
but I really think it's important to
also lead the way um not just talk about
it in terms of seesing the moment and
leading the way we're obviously at a
very pivotal time in technology with AI
how are you looking at incorporating AI
into next store yeah it's um it is an
amazing moment in time I felt so blessed
to show up to the Treman show that was
the GSB um in 2000 because there was a
platform change happening right the
internet
um yes I am that old uh you are all
living through something that I think is
literally orders of magnitude bigger in
terms of a platform change it's such a
seminal moment um you know at a at its
ground level data is everything if we're
going to build these llms um clearly we
see it in action already and so from a
nextd door perspective what I get
excited is we own the local Knowledge
Graph so we have a really unique graph
no one else has it that is one of the
interesting things about social networks
is you have to plant your flag and own
your graph right LinkedIn owns your kind
of uh colleagues your work environment
Facebook is your friends and family but
next door is your local Knowledge Graph
and that data is very Dynamic so if you
think about you know we just grabbed a
coffee over at it turns out there's
multiple Koopa cafes on Stanford campus
who knew but the Koopa Cafe right at the
moment I could easily have tapped in
like here's the special today by
tomorrow that that data is cold it's not
interesting anymore but it's very
different from a Google local search or
even a Yelp search right it's way more
um it's got a lot more color and texture
and so on to it it's also data that's
already pre-labeled thanks to the 85
million people on our platform what I
mean by that is many you'll hear many
companies talking about needing to go
label data it's often kind of Mechanical
Turk is how they do it um but in our
case if you post a recommendation it's
clearly a recommendation if you post
loss clearly lost if you you flag
something for moderation then that gives
us another piece of of labeling to that
data that here's content that a neighbor
feels could or should be moderated um so
it's a very interesting moment as a
platform now we're definitely trying to
you've got the very big guys in the room
guys and gals in the room but like the
the Googles the metas the
um microsofts and then the open Ai
anthropics and I clearly just only
talked about us companies let's look to
what's going on in Asia as well
um but then I think there's what a
practitioner like a next door can do
sitting on top of some of those models
we use um an API to open Ai and a couple
of the places we're we're moving into
right now number one is we're helping
neighbors just make more engaging posts
so we can as you begin to make a post
particularly in areas like
recommendations which is about 20 25% of
of the content that happens on next door
it'll actually recreate the post for you
to make it more engaging so if you
haven't you all have experienced chat
GPT but often I'm talking to a room of
folks from all walks of life all ages
who maybe haven't even heard of
something like chat GPT um and I'm like
this is a way to experience it in a very
non kind of frightening way something's
actually going to help you so that's one
place we've deployed it um and we are
seeing better engagement which is great
um a second way is actually being in
areas of moderation um we've done some
amazing work with folks Dr everheart
sitting right here in the audience and
Spark um if you don't know the doab they
have yes oh hey um it's wonderful what
they've done so we deployed something
actually way back in 2017 called
kindness reminder and it was premised on
the social science of slowing people
down so when we see we're using ml all
the time like long before generative AI
came along AI ml has been in place to
score every post and when a post looks
like it's getting to a heated moment
we'll slow you down by popping up a
little um contextual moment that says
hey neighbors remember great communities
are created with kindness what we write
there is kind of important but actually
the more important thing is that we've
made you read something so now you're
back in this part of your brain where
you have learned to some degree
sometimes big sometimes small to
overcome bias um today that's actually
been very successful for us about 35 to
37% of all people who see the kindness
reminder actually decide to edit their
post because that's what we prompt you
to do but now with generative AI we're
actually now offering you a constructive
way to do it because I think I do think
about the other 70ish percent or 65%
that don't edit I'm like where are you
all at like you just want to not be that
constructive in your community or are
you a bit stuck you don't actually know
how to word it and a way that's
constructive so even we can nudge up
another now maybe it's another 30% we
can grab through an AI That's a great
outcome and I when when I talk to folks
about this if I go back to Northern
Ireland we had to get people around a
table where they did not want to talk to
each other in any sort of constructive
way and remember it was brutal like you
might be sitting at a table with someone
who maybe murdered a member of your
family right these are not like you know
you didn't take your bins at or who was
it you know that parked their car where
I didn't like them this was awful
conversations or what went on in South
Africa right when people had to talk
about what had happened like real trauma
but just getting people around that
table to be constructive look what can
happen right we created peace almost
exactly 25 years ago so on a very much
smaller context if we could just help
people be more constructive can we
actually therefore start to create
better healthier communities because I
actually think the worst thing you can
do is close down the conversation so in
a lot of platforms they move to you know
moderation removing content I'm really
trying to nudge people to say here's how
we can have these tough conversations
but have them in a way where maybe we're
more open to
listening so based on what you described
next door is tackling some of the
biggest issues in society and that we
see right throughout social media
there's also seems to be this very
interesting Confluence or overlap
between what NEX door offers in as a
private company and then facilitating
some public SE traditionally public
sector interests so you mentioned the
hurricane response I know you were also
personally involved in Governor
Newsome's rollout of the co 19 response
so can you speak to a how you see next
door as kind of having this intersection
with government and then B where you see
that those two things should be
delineated and those responsibilities
being kept separate yeah so if you go
back to the definition of a neighborhood
um it's not just the residents right a
healthy thriving neighborhood is the
neighbors but it's the businesses it's
the public agencies it's the school it's
the church and and and right there's
many many organizations at play and so
we view it next door as important to
bring all those organizations to the
platform so today we have about almost
6,000 now I think public agents IES that
can range from the local library to FEMA
to 10 Downing Street to the London
mayor's office right so it can go very
broad nationally down to super super
micro um last year I think it's last
year's data there were1
18 billion doll disasters climate
related disasters in the United States
alone I think the total cost to the
economy was about $175 billion those are
moments where as I talked about with
hurricane Harvey it is a vital frankly
that residents are involved um because
those are the moments where you all are
going to save each other right think
about your own experience in Co I'm sure
even in the GSB Community people stepped
up right you maybe went to the pharmacy
for someone that couldn't that was
immuno compromised um maybe you thought
about an elderly person that might not
be able to get out of their home and so
this is the power of really energizing
Community but there still need needs to
be a link often to the public agency to
know what to do how to do it where where
are supplies you know if there's
sandbags or whatever we want to make
sure that that messaging is coming
through the platform as well and in fact
we just added in in a kind of Trifecta
just added in weather alerts for exactly
this reason so now working with weather
company to say okay in the moment of say
a natural disaster you can both get the
the commercial side weather alert Plus
what's going on with the the local
public sector plus then how can
neighbors the private sector rise to
help so I think that's where you get the
beauty of it I do absolutely believe
that there is a dividing line though
it's usually where the where you know
ultimately the private sector starts to
fail is the moment when the public
sector has to step in um you know do we
do that incredibly well no I it was eye
openening to work on Governor nome's
coid response in good ways because I
could see the diversity around the table
there was groups of people I would never
normally sit at a table with unions for
example um very important and Powerful
groups in California but it was also as
someone who works in the private sector
sometimes frustrating the speed with
which you could get anything or maybe
nothing done because there were so many
competing elements and people rather
than working on the thing here like I
was working particularly on small
businesses small businesses were
devastated if you had an in real life
business if you were a hair salon if you
were even the local pizza shop or
whatever I guess you could still deliver
but you were being devastated and we
couldn't pass something simple as like
how to just get you money to pay your
employees because people the many
constituents around the table who all
had their own thing they wanted wanted
that to get tacked on and then the whole
thing couldn't move forward because
everyone disagreed with all the tack on
um it was a place to see both when you
can almost pull something off to the
side just go work on it make it happen
and ask a little bit less for permission
and just do you could see the power
because then when you do get something
moved when you have the state of
California coming behind you you're no
longer talking about like can we hit
10,000 businesses you're hitting
millions of businesses so it's both the
power of the state but also the slowness
and I'm sure many of you are probably be
doing joint degrees here and thinking
about how do we inject some of that
speed some of the competitive elements
that I think the private sector does so
well into the public sector but also
recognize that a healthy thriving public
sector is needed to kind of catch the
people that fall through the safety net
that's such an incredible impact and it
is everything that I nerd out about at
the GSB I could ask you 30 more
questions in the interest of time
because I do want to leave some room for
the audience to ask questions we do have
one final question that we're asking
each member of our Series this year so
as you know our theme is redefining
tomorrow and so Sarah frier as the CEO
of next store if you could make one
change to redefine tomorrow what would
it be um simply it's that everyone in
the world would know six neighbors or
more and that might sound very facile we
have done a bunch of research on
loneliness in particular um done with an
incredible academic Julian Dr Julian h
instead out of BYU and she used the
platform and used our data to try to
find a statistically significant moment
when feelings of social isolation would
Abate and that magic number is six um
six neighbors so if I think about a
vision for the future I mean of course
I'm talking my book a little bit but I
really would love to see that ritting of
community right that that way I
experienced my parents in action in our
little village in s Mills 2,000 people
but the way I saw them in action because
when that social fabric comes back
together again when you have high social
capital like if you've read any of the
work of Dr putam out of Harvard for
example or Mark granov actually here at
Stamford you'll know that when that
Social Capital starts to build back up
the outcomes broadly are just incredible
you get better health outcomes people
literally live longer like on older
person for example that never gets to
talk to someone else in real life that's
worse in Julian's words worse than
smoking a pack of cigarettes a day in
terms of its impact on your health um
house house prices go up home equity
right usually the largest way that
people save for their future go up right
broken window effect comes into to play
people care about their Community
suddenly everyone starts to care a
little bit more child outcomes go up
right because a neighbor might be
looking out for a kid coming home from
school maybe they're getting bullied on
the way home maybe they don't have
anywhere to go do their homework that's
a little quieter so suddenly a neighbor
kind of pulling them in and saying you
could you work here for an hour till
your parents get home from work but that
can make all the difference so I go back
to I started simple for all of you the
magic number is six neighbors do you
know six neighbors have you taken the
time to just go out maybe knock on a
door say hello to people um but then the
meta effect
the vision for the future right is this
reconnected Society at a Grassroots
level because I really don't believe
it's going to happen tops down that's
amazing I'd like to now turn it over to
the audience and I'm very intrigued
about your six neighbor uh goal for the
future how do you view the like housing
shortage that we have in the US do you
think it'll be more of a shift to multif
family housing like tighter communities
in proximity or do you think it'll be a
mix of what we currently have like do
you guys have a view on that next at
next door your personal view Etc yeah we
we don't have a view per se what we see
happen on next door if I were to kind of
relate it back is that where next door
tends to fly first is if you think about
the the kind of CBD right the central
business district very Urban um when you
get out into sprawl next door tends to
really take off so people are in tight
enough proximity but they they tend to
have Maybe started to move to that
moment where they're renting for a
longer period of time maybe they're
starting to own a house then Suburban
works really well where we tend to break
down is actually in that middle of the
the dut um and then also in hyper rural
rural is not great because local can be
miles and miles apart it's hard to get
enough content doesn't mean it couldn't
happen but it's just much harder and
then in the middle we've spent a lot of
time heads scratching on it is it a pro
problem of the product or is it a
problem is it just like not is there no
product Market fit yet I think it's a
little bit of both I think in those very
urban areas to your point about housing
where maybe people are much tighter
maybe you're going more vertical and so
on you tend to find that there's so much
noise and not a lot of signal so you
have to be really careful what distance
is in fact we're rethinking the product
at the moment to get away from the idea
of hardwired kind of neighborhood
boundaries um we changed it a couple
years ago to just let the algorithm
decide what content was interesting
because everyone's concept of local is
different right to me I'm I live in
Moren I'm actually I think of Moren as
kind of home so I'm quite happy to hear
from a pretty wide area some people get
so irate if it's going beyond their
street they're like why are you sending
this content to me it's not interesting
um but then it also changes based on the
job that you're trying to get done right
if I've lost my dog there's probably
radius that makes sense if it's like
what's that noise it's probably like
like a very small radius if I want a
plumber I'm probably fine going to 20
miles because she's probably got a like
a van and she's going to drive to me so
we kind of realized that we would let
the content do the talking rather than
trying to do this artificial
neighborhood boundary we're shifting it
again it's called project Sun you can
understand why where the person becomes
the center of their own universe and we
let that interplay with the content um
so that CBD I think part of it is um the
product doesn't have good product Market
fit but I also think there's something
in that area which goes back to your
question of like where housing happens
that often people are much more
transient they're not invested in their
Community because they don't have a
reason to care about it um homeowners
very much care about their Community
because it impacts their their house
price um they're often very young um
like maybe just out of college sort of
young um and they they don't really have
a thing about Community yet like their
friends are the people they're happy to
go across a whole city to go hang out
with their friends but they're probably
never going to knock on the door next
door unless it's a complete emergency so
how do we change that psyche and I
actually worry a little bit about
generationally right we're we're more
connected than ever and yet so
disconnected from people who are just
around us in real life so I think that
there's a a whole we could probably Now
call on Dr eard to talk about that but
there's something going on
psychologically with Humanity that
worries me um in terms of fixing where
you began fixing the the homel the the
on house population I mean that is wow
that is a problem that just feels when I
go to work in San Francisco every day
has an element of feeling like an
intractable problem and yet it can't be
it's like anything like if you have a
business problem you just need to break
it down and I think go after it and
pieces and right now I don't see our
public sector as particularly well put
together to do that um but we have to do
something right when we chose our
headquarters at next door we're actually
in the tender line and people come to
visit and they're often a little taken
aback they're like you did you actually
choose this we're like yes we did not
want to live in a tech bubble um I want
my I want me but I want my employees to
kind of as they look outside the office
understand a community that's under Jess
and think about the why we do it rather
than you know coming to work on your bus
you've got your Mac and you got your
snacks in the kitchen and you know you
wonder if you're going to make it home
for your yoga class sry am being a
little factious on purpose like that is
not real life community and I think it's
really important you're all the Business
Leaders of the future I really want you
to think about not putting people into
bubbles and not putting people into
these very synthetic situations but how
do you kind of lean back back into the
communities that you're going to serve
as amazing Business Leaders but like
make sure that you don't create like an
air gap between you and them like
actually get down and be
proximate hi I'm Matt I'm also an nba1
um given you had so many different
senior leadership roles before becoming
CEO um what have you found to be
uniquely challenging about the CEO role
and being at the helm versus your other
role
um and how do you address those
challenges yeah so on this I have now
become the cliche I totally denied it
for my first couple years of being a CEO
but I think the CEO's job is very lonely
and what I'm realizing it's because you
sit between you know a little bit you
have a mask on for your the everyone who
works with you for you at the company
and then you have to outbound to a board
and so you're kind of in this Stuck in
the Middle moment and often you don't
really have someone to talk to about it
because you can't really talk to your
leadership team endlessly about your
board you have to create a little space
and then for your board you need to be
mindful of like what do you want to
really message to them to be consistent
so you don't feel like because they only
get to talk to you every 90 days you
call them a lot in the middle and so you
can be leaning one way at one period and
then you come back 90 days later and
you've done 90 days of work so your your
opinion has evolved but to them a almost
feel like you're flip-flopping um so I'm
very mindful of that when I sit on
boards to try to really be empathetic to
the fact that we feel like we're getting
Whiplash but actually the company's like
no no no we did all this work for 90
days we've just evolved our thinking so
I do think it's lonely and I think
that's the moment where it's really good
to then have a fabric of connection with
other CEOs um and and and not always in
a super formal context because when you
meet people more formally every
everyone's got their mask on and we're
all very like you know we're working on
these business problems and then
sometimes it's good to just go have a
drink with someone that the walls come
down a little and you're like oh that's
happening for you that's happening for
me too and so I think that is the
hardest thing of like sitting in that
air
gap time for one more
question uh hi my name is Eddie um I'm
actually a freshman at the University
but um um my question was in your
different senior leadership roles how
did you uh what was your process for
getting up to speed on different
industries from like Enterprise SAS to
fintech to uh consumer internet oh thank
you and thank you for coming over
crossing the road
yay some of some of my best moments at
the GSB were actually when I crossed
back the other side um I was talking I
did a Spanish class I did an engineering
class I think I did an art class at one
stage I loved it so take advantage
people come both ways um that is a great
question because it's a skill like as a
consultant it's actually a skill you
have to learn because pretty much you go
to meet your client and it might be the
first time you've ever seen their
industry but you're being paid to show
up and actually consult them and so you
cannot be the you know you cannot be
ignorant for too long a period so a I'm
an Avid Reader um to begin with and I
really try to not narrow my reading
there I actually still get the paper
Wall Street Journal don't laugh at me
but I do that because when I find one I
read online I naturally curate myself
I'm you know they ask you to right you
it's like what are you interested in
technology and suddenly everything
you're reading seems so like oh they
picked it for me because they did it's
an algorithm versus when I open up the
Wall Street Journal I'm kind of find
myself reading almost some they they
feel random at the time but why I think
that's important is if you think about
the course of you span of your career or
your life right you kind of read enough
interesting different things there's
moments in time where suddenly it
becomes very apropo of the moment um
beyond the paper I am an avid Avid
Reader I I try to read 52 books a year
it's my personal goal every year I
usually get into the 40s this year's a
good year actually um because there's a
lot going on with things like Ai and so
I tend to again read because I I can
usually find then ways that it's going
to matter in the situation I'm in um the
book that I really like a lot on this is
called range and it's this idea of like
you actually do become a better leader
when you have all of these different um
skills feeding in um I think one of
their archetypes is Leonardo Da Vinci
and I read range at the same time as I
read Walter is ison's um biography of Da
Vinci and it was fascinating because
here you had this incredibly curious
individual that was a sculptor but to
understand how metal would flow to
sculpt he was actually leaning on work
he' done around the water system in
Italy which then was tied back to how
blood pumped in the human body when he
was doing dissections and so on and so I
think about that a lot when people are
like oh you've done so many different
things I'm like hell no like like it's
very we're very narrow actually relative
to I think how humans used to be so
reading is a big part of it and then
particularly I think in your 30 6090 so
when you join something new 30 is just
listen and try to I often try to have
three questions that I ask every single
person I meet with and I'm not trying to
I I am going to compare and contrast
ultimately but it kind of you're
listening but you've got some framework
in the
once you get to 30 people want you to do
stuff and that's kind of the dangerous
moment because you still actually don't
know enough so in 30 to 60 I normally
try to start to find maybe smaller
things where I can put some points on
the board at 90 I think you have to
start acting and that's when you have to
come with kind of a first push of what's
my strategy top down um and then from
there my tactics I think a lot of people
in life are very much ready fire Aim so
they need for speed to get going it's
worth taking that moment to write down
strategically what you're trying to do
and then the tactics build from there
good strategy should be multi it'll last
multi-e you don't have to roll it all
out 90 days that would be a lot but you
need to have a frame that at least can
stay somewhat true over a longer
Arc such a good question thank you
lovely to meet you thank you so much
Sarah like any good GSB I know you have
the rest of your day planned out by five
minute increments
I do so I and so I want to keep you on
time what we're going to finish with is
a quick lightning round so I'm G to ask
you it's a view from the top tradition
I'm GNA ask you five questions in Rapid
Fire we're going to finish in two
minutes to be perfectly on time okay
let's do this and it'll be a fill in-
the blank so I'll say the beginning of
the sentence and you finish it with a
short phrase or word that first pops
into your mind okay the one thing city
Folk don't understand about growing up
in the country is
animals like they're
messy the biggest culture shock I faced
moving from Ireland in the UK to America
was
oh just sense of humor yeah I'm
sorry that bad I'm not going to tell you
which way you're all
guessing the most applicable lesson I
learned from a masters of Engineering in
the study of metals is how to release
gold out of sulfi doors no um yeah that
I actually love seeing something in a
lab come alive in the real world my
favorite memory of the GSB
is meeting my
[Laughter]
[Applause]
husband second only to being cold called
in gar stoner's class the first time I
walked into
it and last but not least if I could put
up a bill board in town square with one
tagline of advice for everyone here in
the audience it would say uh so I'm
stealing my favorite Irish poet Sheamus
heini his epit he buried very close to
our grips very Irish start talking about
a burial right at the end of everything
um but I love this um walk on air
despite your better
judgment if you think about
it it's good take risks your intuition
let it guide you don't always always be
logic driven but walk on air despite
your better judgment that is the most
beautifully poetic note I think any view
from the top has ever ended on Sarah it
has been such an honor and a pleasure
interviewing you and we wish you the
most success in your career and
everything moving forward thank you much
amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing